visite de stephen harper dans les taudis
collections l'une des rares
circonscriptions conservatrices de
toronto temps six jours seulement les
canadiens et les canadiennes vont
choisir un gouvernement dernier blitz
pour défendre ses sièges dont il a tant
besoin
au point de renouer prudemment avec les
frères ford deux invités vedettes mais
une foule bien modeste à peine une
centaine de personnes est ce un signe
que la campagne s'essouffle son porte
parole parle plutôt d'une décision
stratégique
on ne veut pas un aux bénévoles ici dit
il mais plutôt sur le terrain pour
rencontrer les électeurs de l'autre côté
de toronto le contraste peut
difficilement être plus frappants
alimenté par l'énergie de ses partisans
justin trudeau sillonne des comptes et
qui souhaitent reprendre un [ __ ] mais le
chef libéral maintien surtout qu'il
n'est pas question d'appuyer un éventuel
gouvernement minoritaire de stephen
harper les russes comme steve hewitt
chalk river a partagé par les autres
chefs son temps est révolu
il est temps de médecine à la porte et
oui je vais le faire à la première
occasion
comme cette règle me suis rappelé ce
premier ministre même s'il finissait
premier dans le cadre d'un gouvernement
minoritaire
or même devant des adversaires unanime
stephen harper n'ose plus évoqués comme
en 2011 la nécessité d'obtenir une
majorité qui lie à un choix fondamental
dans cette élection pour l'économie et
c'est le choix entre notre parti est
franchement tous les autres partis qui
hante plus ou moins la même approche une
approche des dépenses sans contrôle
financé par des coupeurs de bénéfices
par des augmentations de taxes et impôts
par des déficits permanents discours
prudent pour suivre un peu et une
campagne plus défensif qu'en 2011 avec
des journées moins remplis des
événements
- frais qu'un sentiment d'urgence mail
à quelques jours du vote et si daniel
thibault radio canada toronto